all right so let's just breathe i'm
going to breathe through it and have
jordan
help look if jordan can help trevor get
through a big day he can help me get
through this moment too
uh joining me here on the rich eisen
show the man who was uh right by
trevor lawrence's side jordan palmer how
are you sir
i'm doing well how are you doing rich
i'm doing fine how are you
great i'm heading to the airport back to
where you're from
okay your neck of the woods in
california and i'm uh i'm out here in
south carolina right now
okay so i'm gonna ask you the uh most
important question of the day
jordan um uh did uh
did well did trevor extra moisturize uh
did he extra
put more conditioner in his hair today
what'd he do yeah really focused on
getting a head and shoulders deal i
thought he did a great job
good um no he uh i don't think he has
bad hair days
rich like you and i have had over the
years i don't think he has that
he looked terrific jordan he looked
terrific uh
walk me through what uh how you prepared
him for today and how you thought it
went
what do you got for me well i i think
yeah i think for some context i mean it
was pretty unprecedented if you think
about it that
i don't know you've been doing this
longer than me but i haven't seen
somebody
bump their pro day up a month to
accommodate and to go ahead and show it
and
you know he's really only been throwing
two weeks just because you know
you have the playoffs you do all that
stuff and we were preparing for a later
pro day and so you know to only have two
weeks and
um there's there's these kind of these
college players they throw when they're
at a nike school they throw nike
footballs and
there's two kinds there's a large and
the small girth you know size and so
they throw a smaller so when you go from
the small one at clemson to the nfl
there's just a lot of different changes
and so between the new footwork kind of
cramming it in there and
and uh only a couple weeks throwing i
mean i i think
the big takeaway from today is if
anybody could have said no to this
it's him and he didn't showed up
spun it and didn't let any of that stuff
bother him and kind of looked like what
we all thought he was which is uh
the best player in this draft all right
and then we uh we saw uh from my
colleague in nfl media group jane slater
she instagrammed out the
the play sheet uh i guess that uh that
the script
that you put him through what what did
you put together that you thought
um needed to show off all of his
uh acumen all of his abilities
well i was going to try i was going with
the strategy of like let's just have
everybody go
deep a bunch and then everyone i
realized everyone's going to get tired
so
now we uh basically is there's a bunch
of
new stuff right anybody going from
college to pro these days you know a lot
of these college guys aren't gone a lot
so
um without knowing exactly what's going
to happen here
coming up um we just wanted to show that
hey here's all the different play action
footwork that any system would ask you
to do
they may have a different name but it's
the same thing so
instead of just throwing a flat route
let's do it off of a play action and and
really it was just getting a chance to
show all the different footwork that
he's going to be asked to do
i'm in every type of throw i'm not big
on doing a hundred throws to show
you know anything there it's really just
can you make all the different throws
whether it's layer touch
drive feel to the sideline over the top
and um
you know i wasn't surprised at all it
looked like he he did a great job in
every category and
and um did what he wanted to do great
job a great name for the eight-yard stop
jordan
noticed that one too kobe yeah much
respect
well i mean was kobe six six i don't
know i mean this guy
he wasn't but it's an eight-yard route
okay so
i think that's where that name comes
from and um
but uh but yeah mix it in try to use the
different terminology for different
folks that are there too
um and uh yeah you did a great job
you've been the qb consultant for
quite quite a few people jordan uh
including many who have gone on to great
things in the nfl where does trevor
lawrence rank for you
i mean he's right up there i think the
biggest thing with with trevor
um and really i felt this way like
before started working out
is if you think about what his last four
years have been like okay so you know
software in high school he's got you
know an offer from every school in the
country
and you say what does that have to do
with the nfl well okay
that means every single time he steps on
the field for a seven on seven
tournament
um every single kids waiting to pick him
off and try and beat them that day and
that their camera phones out
and then you know he goes through the
programs like elite eleven that you and
i talked about
that's a tv show they're mic'd up
they're around the experience that you
get
i know a lot of guys from being on hard
knocks and a lot of guys who does the
first time they've ever been mic'd up
they're new to that
and then you look at what happened is
true freshman year it's not just that he
won a national championship
it's that he was replacing deshaun
watson who this big beautiful facility
that we were throwing in today
john watson built that place so with
like to follow in those steps and then
come in and have instant success right
away
um i just look at his last couple of
years and everything he's been through
and this offseason
he's a big reason we played football he
started
the let us play movement and would use
his platform for that and when
social injustice he was at the front and
center that so this guy
has just done so many things in college
that is stuff that i think franchise
quarterbacks
have to go through and most of them
learn how to do it when they get to the
league
trevor's got three or four years of
experience of dealing with that
before he touches a football i'd say
that advantage is in his favor if it
comes to is he going to be one of these
greats yeah and of course
obviously he replaced uh desean or he
followed desean watson in terms of the
level of expectation that watson had
already set but he really replaced kelly
bryant
who uh transferred who basically and
that was that was a big to-do
uh at clemson at the time certainly put
a lot of spotlight and pressure on
trevor
uh in his initial starts there and then
the rest is literally history
and you know the the concept is he's
going to be first overall and
that's that but how many teams came up
to you today how many how many pictures
there's a handful handful of guys
teams there and you know some of these
guys are all friends from different
things as well
right um these producers funk's gonna
get to run into people i mean
you know art smith was the tight end
coach in tennessee when i was there you
know what i mean so now
finally seeing the head coach of the
atlanta falcons is great but um
but yeah i think it was a good turnout
considering uh what the
situation is and being early and um and
i thought he handled himself really well
one of my favorite jordan palmer a few
more minutes left with the qb consultant
uh jordan palmer who
was uh trevor lawrence's consultant for
the pro day today here on the rich
island show
so um one of my favorite stories that
dion sanders told me from his days
uh at the combine when he was being
drafted is he would ask uh
teams that were interested in him where
are you drafting and if it wasn't high
enough he would just walk away saying
you have no shot
so um now obviously anything can happen
in the nfl but did
any of those moments cross your mind or
you have to name the team where somebody
comes up to you asking about trevor
you're like what the hell are you asking
me for
no i know i think everyone's intrigued
and they've all seen them and
they want to know and at the same time
there's a crazy year i mean look at we
were the names that were all thrown
around
who could go where i mean who knows
what's gonna happen and so um i think
that's a piece of it as well as
no one could definitively very few teams
can definitely say who what they're
going to do next year quarterback i
think more so than ever
and so uh it opens up the uh the the
the mind for opportu for uh um
you know for intrigue here to kind of
figure out what are the different
options that said how much have you
spoken have you already broken a
personal record of how much you've
spoken to urban meyer
at all or or what oh we actually go way
back just from
you know as you run into folks over the
years whether it's an american century
classic in tahoe or other places
[Laughter]
well you're definitely talking nbc
sports language here on nbc sports in
peacock you know so
but this is i mean how do you let's put
it this way then let me ask you this
question
how do you think he will fit what urban
meyer and daryl
darren bevel daryl bevel are going to be
cooking up
in jacksonville how do you think that
well i i think if if that if that aligns
i think it's it's an awesome fit i think
the thing about urban is like he's just
kind of one everywhere we all know that
he wanted florida and ohio state but
he won a bowling green and he wanted at
utah
and um and so i think that he has the
right approach i don't think he has any
interest in
taking a big job and hoping things work
out i think he's trying to win a super
bowl and win it immediately
and that's just how he's always been and
and then darrell beville's have so much
success with
uh with quarterbacks that are less
mobile and quarterbacks that are really
mobile like russell and so
when you know how to design for both
types of players and and trevor
certainly mobile
and be able to move him around uh but
can play from the pocket i i do i you
know
as a as a really what i am as a fan of
trevor as a fan i get excited
um you know about the opportunity to do
that and then you know branch on higher
pass game coordinator he's
he's uh he's been around a lot of these
young guys used with the young mark
sanchez and
um he's impressed with russell as well
and so there's just a lot of knowledge
in that room and
and i don't know too much about the rest
of the staff and all the other things
there but
um i know that i know those three names
and and what they're about and i think
uh
you know i i sure hope it's trevor and
they get an opportunity
for those guys i think only good stuff's
gonna happen before i let you go what
about the left shoulder that needs
surgery
what's what can you tell me about that
for traveling i think it's just a
standard deal you know i don't that's
not my world
uh but i think it's just a standard deal
and um
it's the kind of surgery where that
surgeon does like eight of those that
day
you know what i mean it's just a total
standard deal and
uh i wouldn't be surprised if if the
surgeons done
a lot of nfl players uh that surgery
this offseason
um so it's a routine deal and the rehab
is what it is and
moving it up early was just a great move
by his team
um and by trevor to move it up so that
he can really actually get ready for
this
rookie season instead of um having a
rehab late in the off season okay
i just think the kids handled it really
well from start to finish okay last
thing for you the video that we've been
playing quite a bit throughout the day
and has gone viral what do we call what
do we call
this uh this play on your script of him
uh fading back running uh running in
what seems to be in circles before
launching it 70 yards down the field
jordan what are we well all it is is
just a busted play right so i have
somebody run a curl
and then i move him like as if
somebody's chasing him both directions
and sets up and
i think that's just the best way to show
how far a guy can throw i don't like
standing there just chucking it at some
line
um and so it just insinuates hey look
the play breaks down look how mobile he
is
too somebody runs naked down that
behind the coverage he can he can make
that play as well something is just a
good way to kinda
and those things often put any you know
with any quarterback any any questions
about a quarterback's arm shrink whether
that's
whoever that is um that's a good one to
put it to bed because he got a lot on
that
and then do you do you also tell him
that after it's completed
um what you should do is lift your shirt
so you can show your abs uh wipe your
face with that and then just
uh when i know that that's going to be
on camera let me come by and dab you up
just you was that a veteran try and
get a photo of it and then superimpose
my face on his so
i could lie to my wife and tell her that
i do have apps no but you dapped him up
like that's a veteran move you know you
you know that that's just that's going
to be the highlight of the day and then
you step in jordan that was a veteran
move i noticed that
i saw that nice it was nice probably
kidding it's not your first starting
biggest moment he's not been in some
bigger situations in a uh pro day in
front of a few folks okay no just for
you though i'm appreciating you too
uh so josh allen's your guy too right
nick correct
uh he is yeah we spent a lot of time
together oh
boy what a year for him huh what about
him
what about that kid jordan huh i mean
sky's the limit
um you know i think i think if you look
wrote a list together
of the most just physically talented
players ever play the position
i don't know who else is on that list
but he sure is and he might be at the
top of it in terms of
you know he's faster than most the fast
guys and he's 245
and i don't know if his arm is the
strongest in the league
or his path is stronger but whatever it
doesn't matter there's two guys standing
over there by themselves
i mean um and just the complete package
and then the on top of that there are
fast guys who aren't good runners
and there are slower guys who are good
runners he's a fast guy that's also a
good runner so you just look at all the
pieces and
i'll say this he's really fun to work
with he's uh you've probably interviewed
him he's a
human to hang out with as there is what
a good human just a good dude and
and those i remember you were telling me
those accuracy things that people you're
hearing about forget it
like don't worry about that and now look
at them i mean seriously yeah this is
yeah a lot of people say you can't coach
accuracy or you can't get more accurate
as a player that's just people who
haven't had success doing it so
um like i told you i mean it's a it's a
thing that he's going to end up owning
and
and it happened faster than i thought it
would um but just because i've never
seen anything in big girl that quick but
um and then and honestly ken dorsey is
quarterback coach brian dabol
that offensive coordinator and what
brandon bean has assembled around them
um you know josh is certainly a lot of
credit is due there
and but a lot of credits due to that
staff and the way that that front office
has built that team because
this was not a good year this was the
start of something that we're going to
get
used to seeing you're the man jordan
thanks for the time save flight let's
get let's connect over the next couple
weeks that's it you bet thank you that's
uh jordan palmer
uh here on the rich eisen show one of
the tops in his game
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here